good morning John there are certain
things that you only get the chance to
do once in your whole lifetime and if
you don't do it you never get to do it
again and one of those things is making
a tier list of articles about your
time of course decided to do this the
moment that the New York Post article
came out but we'll get to that one we're
going to start with my hometown
newspaper The Missoulian which did a
fine job except they didn't actually do
this it's just from The Wire this is my
town now I said that the article is fine
but John they do mention you in the
second paragraph which is a little early
for me and they also picked out the
saddest looking frame from my video so
this is going to be e-tier this one's
from the decider and I've never noticed
this before but most of these headlines
will be framed as the news is that I'm
revealing something not that the news is
that something is happening to me which
I actually quite like the news is that I
have made this information available
it's Health stuff so the news isn't that
I have cancer it's that I've revealed
that I have cancer now saying this sucks
so bad in the headline I don't like that
because that makes it sound bad and
scary and they didn't mention you John
early on but there is a whole blurb that
says more on John Green so that's going
to put that in the e-tier for me as well
we're starting off week CBS News as you
might be unsurprised to hear fine job
I'm going to put this one in the B Tier
New York Times uh I like this headline
hankery novelist and YouTube Star not
even author novelist also no scare
quotes it's as treatable cancer great
love that now John you do make an early
appearance in paragraph number three but
then they go on to give me two full
paragraphs about my books which
fantastic love that I'm gonna give that
an a the Hill's got me in as a popular
YouTuber and Tick Tock Creator revealing
my diagnosis I like that but it's middle
of the past NPR Here in the pop culture
section YouTube star that's what I get
and I'll allow it did a good job of
condensing things down real quick
getting the point across but then the
best part is that in the NPR article the
author left me some suggestions for a
bummer free media this to me seemed like
the kind of person who's probably in the
community so I did check it out Tilda
Wilson uh got it They Might Be Giants
lyric and the Twitter bio and follows me
on Twitter so we're just gonna guess
that this isn't their first exposure
nerdfighteria so NPR alone by itself in
the S tier for a very nice condensed
article that got the point across and
told me to play Animal Crossing CNN's
going to get a point off for just
calling me YouTuber and not YouTube Star
so it would have been an egg but it's
going to be a b Los Angeles Times kicks
it off with Hank Green YouTube star and
John Green's brother it's a good article
but I did find that a little bit
disappointing especially because you
actually can put in for Google purposes
like the shortened version of the
headline for search results and that one
just says Hank Green John Green's
brother has cancer it sucks so I
apologize for this LA times but you're
heading in for that D tier now huffpo
took a Miss on the news is the reveal
angle and just said Hank Green has
cancer and instead the news is what is
Hodgkin's lymphoma which I actually like
they interviewed somebody from the
Leukemia and Lymphoma Society they
talked to an oncologist I'm gonna put
this in the S this was the daily gossip
we got some Jay-Z and Beyonce news here
but as you scroll down Hank Green has
been diagnosed with cancer and live
action Powerpuff Girls dead at the CW so
that's gonna go in the left here I don't
feel like that's the right vibe I think
you got the vibrant variety gave me a
write-up I like this write-up because
it's more about the entertainment
industry part of things which I am a
part of and they did a good old job
about that they put the fact that I'm
going to miss VidCon in the headline I
understand that's sort of like the most
applicable news here to variety but
still but the Variety article does in
green quoted vidcon's tweet and said
this is so frustrating please have so so
much fun at VidCon without me and
including that bonus Point USA
vlogger Hank Green opens about cancer
diagnosis
news it is bad news but like that's
scary and I know what you're trying to
do and I don't like it so I'm gonna give
you but they did give up the novel so
I'm gonna bump you up to a c okay the
today's Show's perspective I liked a lot
here's what he wants his fans to know
that's a great frame and I liked it so
I'm gonna put you with NPR in the S10
and finally we're going to end off with
our little friends the New York Post
this is Hank Green reveals cancer
diagnosis author says it sucks so bad I
did get author in there so that's a
bonus point but you're gonna get a
negative bonus Point later on you'll see
again I feel a little bit of the scare
quote Vibe behind the suck so bad part
but most importantly later in the
article it says this sucks so bad but
I'm already learning so much mostly
about myself you noted in the video's
description and then used this picture
what what what what are you doing look
at their tweet about it they put the
pencil picture in the tweet and that's
not even the strangest thing I was
actually in the New York Post two times
last week the other time for an article
called invisible creatures are having
sex on your face while you sleep which
you could find out about on Journey to
the micro Cosmos so apparently I have
some fans over there anyway yeah that's
F tier which completes our tier list
everybody this has obviously been a
pretty tough time for me are now a week
after my first chemo feeling much better
than I was a few days ago chemo has been
pretty miserable already but I'm getting
amazing care and I have so much support
and there's been so much good vibes and
I just can't say how much I appreciate
it it has really pushed me through some
of the hard times and feeling Not Alone
In A Moment Like This is a fantastic
privilege I'm really glad I was feeling
up to make a video today John I'll see
you on Tuesday